okay the blow up happens what were those
nine or ten days like
well the weirdest thing about a lot of
those days is something happened that
had never happened before
Sam went silence everybody was like what
the hell for the first time ever our our
CEO who won't shut up is not saying
anything
[Music]
all right guys bang bang I'm super
excited to talk to Brady he's got a
brand new book out called SBF how the
FTX bankruptcy Unwound crypto's very bad
good guy I've read the whole thing
here's my proof of work I got all my
little notes and highlights Etc uh Brady
I thought a great place to start is why
write this book is it just the biggest
story in finance uh the biggest story in
crypto was it just you had a front row
seat like what what drove you to write
this and do it so quickly
well I mean to be perfectly honest it
was Wiley's idea the publisher they
wanted to do it they thought it made
sense to get a book out quickly on this
topic and they sought me out uh and
asked me to do it and I've always wanted
to do books uh but I think it's a great
story in fact I a part of the backstory
of it is I had already been thinking
about a book that was related to Sam
anyway I I had a book proposal I had
written that hadn't gone anywhere
um for the sushi swap specific story
which is sort of I view is Sam's kind of
Debut as a leader in the crypto world
and so I had already done a ton of work
on that so that whole kind of middle
part of the book that covers that was
like largely ready
um so I'd already been thinking about
him as a character and then when Wiley
was like we think this would be a good
story to do I was like obviously it
would be a good story to do um so I
agreed to do it all right so in the book
you turn the the first draft into Wiley
and December 30th 2022 and then you
basically get a chance to interview Sam
and you've got a quote in uh in in the
book that I thought was just fascinating
he basically says in terms of facing the
future I think I'm just going to tell
the truth and see what happens and I
certainly don't agree with the public
narrative but that's not for me to
decide at the end of the day I think
like my biggest concern is that the
incredibly toxic media environment will
mean that there's no way for me to have
a fair trial and that no matter what
happens there will be too much political
and public pressure to find me guilty
and that it won't matter what really
happened
you've talked to them you've done all
the work all this stuff does the truth
matter in this story or is there already
this kind of preconceived hey they broke
the law and they're all going to get in
trouble like how do you kind of get out
of it because outside of law enforcement
you probably are one of the people
who've done the most work on what
exactly has happened here in order to be
able to write a book about it
yeah I think the truth does matter and
you know
one thing that's a bummer about doing a
book is you can't hear the tone of his
voice towards the end of that
conversation but
I found him to be defiant when we talked
I think it was December 31st uh of last
year
um and one of the things he and I also
quote him in saying this elsewhere in
the book is he says you know he didn't
really think the government had real
evidence against him but has time has
gone on like particularly this
um additional charge that came out about
the bribery in China it does seem like
they do have a decent amount of evidence
and you know I'll be curious I don't I
don't think he's going to take a plea at
some point but I think one of the things
that really struck me is he thought he
had a case but it does seem as time goes
on that there's more and more evidence
that they really did do
some pretty bad things so I think the
truth does matter but I do think the
truth is probably going to be on the
side of the courts but I mean you know
for law enforcement but we'll see so in
the book you highlight this idea of like
basically Sam appears to have served a
purpose that everyone was looking for
everyone wanted to find the hero
everyone wanted to find the person that
was going to kind of save the world and
in it you say sam begman freed offered a
story that you wanted to believe the
talkative boy billionaire who would turn
the wealth creation engine of
cryptocurrency into a robber barons War
chest with which he could fix the world
and you want to talk about Andrew
Carnegie and how you know we we put all
of these people on a pedestal today but
actually they might have been doing some
pretty bad [__] when they were really
kind of coming up and creating wealth
and then at the end of that chapter you
say what in fact the lesson of SBF is
this the last thing anyone needs is a
hero and I thought that was so good in
terms of that might just be in life in
general but definitely in a crypto
Market where it seemed like he was able
to capture this narrative how much of
that was intentional versus kind of the
media just was looking and they found
somebody and then they built this
character out of nowhere and Sam didn't
have that much to do with it
well I think it was a collaboration I
don't know if Sam set out to do it but
he certainly loved it once it got going
you know and he he played into it I I do
think Sam loved the attention I do think
he loved this story about himself I
think Sam wanted to be the guy to save
the world and it wasn't just he wanted
the world to be saved he wanted himself
to be the one who saved it so I think
all of those things are true so I think
Sam was complicit in building this story
and really liked it that he was getting
to take on that role so that is from a
mainstream media narrative right and
obviously we saw everyone write articles
magazine covers uh conferences like the
whole thing but then you had this one
line in the book that just cracked me up
you said FTX is only real Insurance on
customer deposits was a meme and I think
what it really highlights here is this
idea of like the mainstream media is
what traditional Finance is used to they
participate they manipulate in some ways
they they hold back information they
feed it information they do all that
stuff
crypto has the whole meme culture and
Twitter and Telegram and like a whole
almost like alternative Universe of
content and information that gets played
out and what you really are highlighting
here is like customer deposits and
insurance or no laughing matter like
that's actually a very real Concept in
traditional Finance but when you mix it
with crypto this idea that like maybe
customer deposits were being held up by
a meme what do you mean by that
well it's just this idea that he that
Sam had created this idea that he was
smart and safe and you could trust him
um but you know when you look at when
you when you started to dig in more into
FTX
um one thing one you know a lot of
people a lot of fingers are being
pointed at CZ and binance these days for
example and look I I have no doubt that
they've probably done some things that
you know law enforcement wouldn't love
that they did but one real striking
difference between the two of them and I
know people had critiques of this model
but binance has been pretty upfront
about which wallets are it's you know
it's like we'll publish all of our wild
addresses we'll tell you know we'll tell
you what's there have a look
um and that inspires a certain amount of
trust and because I understand it FTX
has always been pretty hesitant about
doing that right and yet people were
like willing to trust them so much
because he just had this whole vibe of
being a smart a smart guy who was on the
level who was doing everything right and
people bought into that so it was kind
of just a meme
at one point you said he's a geek but a
geek with swagger and I thought I had
not heard anyone say that before what do
you mean by a geek with swagger well I'm
pushing back there on this idea that he
also I think helped construct this idea
that he was this um dorky a lot of
people calling him autistic you know uh
awkward guy which I don't think is at
all right I think you know I don't know
if you've ever talked to him I have he's
a fun guy to talk to he's got social
skills he's Charming you know this is a
guy who who plays up sort of a geek is a
person who has a very specific interest
that not everyone is into but it doesn't
necessarily mean like they're like a
nerd they use it as a crutch you know he
just has these specific interests and uh
so I think he actually was a lot cooler
than people want to admit in his story
and he used this whole Narrative of
awkwardness to kind of protect himself
but the truth is he was like the super
confident person who you know wanted to
be in charge of fixing the world so
that's what I mean by the Swagger so at
one point you talk about the Miami Heat
arena deal and you say the heat deal had
the scent of hubris and you point out
that about six weeks after that
announcement uh SPF said it's been a
pretty good year for us to the point
where frankly we don't need to rely on
the full old 19 years to have the funds
for paying for the arena and I thought
the next paragraph of what you wrote in
this book was like alarm system you know
loud siren you said the Greeks wrote
whole tragedies warning against this
kind of talk SPF would have probably
called such cautionary tales irrational
and they might be but they are also
Lindy and they look pretty good right
now and so how much of this was just
pure arrogance and hubris versus uh you
know hey we believe in ourselves and you
kind of need that to be successful and
then [__] kind of went sideways but it's
not necessarily because of arrogant
arrogance and hubris
you know that that moment of the Miami
Heat thing is an important one for me
kind of personally you know I don't know
that I could prove this to people they
could just be saying I'm sort of telling
a story
um to make myself look smarter later but
I can remember the day that that quote
came out because I had been pretty into
the Sam story and even was still at that
point but that was the first time that I
was kind of personally I was like bro
you're you're putting your name on an
arena right now like this just does not
it seems too early you know this just
seems way too early and you know you've
read the book you know that I have
sources in there who say
um that kind of marked a moment where
you started to get kind of celebrity
hungry um and I think that's the moment
where he got the taste of Fame and you
know it started to go to his head and we
sort of see the repercussions of that
later
so what I thought was interesting is
like you call out these moments that you
personally experienced or you you saw
you know along the way and I think
you're like pretty honest you're like
hey look for a long time like I bought
into the story and you know had a
certain View and then over time I got
more and more data and like my view
changed and obviously there was kind of
this big you know moment uh towards the
end but you said that in uh the start of
2022 SBF told you uh my reading now
given what I know now which is still not
everything is that basically there's
some number of black swans that would
necessary that would be necessary to
blow out Alameda and like that number
was slowly decreased over the course of
the year and so when I read that is like
21 was this amazing year for investors
across all asset classes crypto
specifically right we had all-time high
in Bitcoin and many other asset prices
hedge funds were literally just like
printing money they were returning
Distributing and all this stuff and so
when you take the Miami Heat arena the
celebrity hungry stuff and then you add
in the performance like it's easy to see
how you start to believe that like you
actually are really really good at
playing this game right 2022 happens and
when there's a drawdown you know the
famous Warren Buffett quote of like when
the water goes out you see you know
who's naked and yeah there were
definitely the moments of Luna Terra Etc
that kind of put increased pressure but
is it actually something where like 21
created the exposure that took them down
in 22. in your opinion or do you think
that there was like specific things they
made decisions they made in 2022 that
actually was the undoing
well
the thing you have to understand about
Sam I I don't I don't know that I have a
great answer to that question I mean
it's just speculation but I do think one
of the things I came to understand about
Sam was he had this Viewpoint that FTX
needed to get huge as fast as humanly
possible so it could it could have a
moat around it that no one could beat
and I think
I think they had a culture where they
had gotten very big in 21 and they were
like well we need to make a few more
really big bets so that no one can ever
overtake us I think they were hungry to
like overtake binance or something like
that to be the biggest and so I think
where it might have been smart to be
like
wow this is really blown up this really
looks like the top we should start
cashing out and planning for a winter
they were like no we can get a few more
wins in here like I'm pretty sure you
know I think I'm pretty sure they were I
don't know for sure but I'm pretty sure
they played Tara I'm pretty sure they
played the um that crazy defy thing that
um I mentioned the book the name is
eluding me right now but that happened
in January that was kind of the first
blow up of 2022 that people don't talk
about as much the really weird the it
was the OM Fork on on Avalanche I think
they were in there so I think they were
going for a few final big swings to
cement themselves the top and and here
and palm this is one of the parts of the
story that I am most confused about with
Sam because you know you and I have both
been around for a minute right so we
both have some appreciation for like
things go up and then they really go
down and you have to do things
differently in those times I mean I'm
not an investor but I still you know I
guess you know yeah I see what happens
right what's confusing about Sam is he
was there for 2018 too you know he
started in 2017. so this is what I'm
confused about with him is just like I
feel like those of us who went through
2017 and 2018 kind of know how to read
the tea leaves and just like okay it's
time to cash out now it's time to start
going careful
for whatever crazy reason they didn't
you know he I don't know he thought this
time is different or what but um yeah I
think that was it they wanted they
wanted to overtake binance and um and
stay in second place through crypto
winner wasn't an option and Sam has said
this you know and I quote him in the 80
000 hours podcast for example saying
this he was always willing to bet the
farm he was always willing to take that
double or nothing bet to go even bigger
or lose everything
um which I think was fine until he
launched FTX and it was no longer
just his money he was playing with it
was no longer just house money playing
with he started playing with everyone
else's money too how much of it you
mentioned in in the book suzu talks
about kind of the super cycle and the
institutional participation means it's
different this time there's not gonna be
this big drawdown do you think that Sam
just kind of bought into similar
thinking whether it was that specific
Theory or or something like that and
that's why he played it differently or
do you think that it was just Mis you
know Market timing there's plenty of
people who are professional investors
who just miss it right uh they think
it's going higher or going longer or
whatever and it ends up actually
crashing before they can get out
I don't know I I think I do think and
and everybody sort of told me all my
various sources told me some some I
reported on some I didn't
um you know some were people who didn't
want to you know be included in the book
but still kind of talk to me a little
bit a lot of people tell me that when
you interacted with the Alameda crew and
the FTX crew there definitely was this
whole vibe of where the smartest kids in
the room kind of thing and I wonder if
kind of um
they bought their own nonsense that like
we can always win and we can always come
out on top and that's certainly what it
kind of looks like you know I mean but
then like doubling down in mid 2022 and
like buying every company in sight it
certainly made it look like they could
always find a way to get out
so talking about being overly honest uh
you have a section in the book where uh
you basically rehash what do Quan said
on my podcast which I I took a lot of
[__] for people were very pissed that he
came on the podcast that I was even want
to talk to him Etc and my thought
process at the time was like this is the
biggest buyer of Bitcoin in the world at
the moment how are we not going to talk
to him about what he's doing with
Bitcoin right right and so what you say
in the book is
um you know he talks about the purchase
of Bitcoin he was Frank about the risk
Tara needed Bitcoin as an extra defense
he explained and then later on you say
this was the death spiral that everyone
knew was the chief risk in a design like
Tara's and do Quan explained it to pomp
without any spin he just said it and so
what I always think about is like if you
go and you interview a big hedge fund
manager in the traditional Financial
World they ain't saying [__] they got
their talking points they're sticking to
it right you can ask them anything what
color is the sky they'll tell you about
how we have you know uh uh risk
mitigated investment strategy for
long-term hold blah blah whatever yeah
crypto not like that I mean right to see
dokwon literally almost call a shot on
hey if it works this is what's gonna
happen if it doesn't work it'll be for
this reason and everything will blow up
is shocking in hindsight which I think
you're kind of calling out here in the
book explain a little bit more as you
see that now with the hindsight bias
like how you read into that
well I mean I think it I think it the
way I understand that is
you know I know
dough kind of well I mean we've never
met in person but we've talked a bunch
of times I think I got a handle on his
Vibe uh and I read it at the time as a
flex you know like him saying like I
will just admit what the biggest risk is
and I think I can mitigate that risk and
get around it because I'm so smart and
clever and I also think he really
thought that he had done a very smart
thing by buying all this Bitcoin as a
bulwark I think he thought it was an I
mean it turned out it was like a it was
a bunch of tissue paper you know we
learned it it did nothing as that as the
spiral happened but um I think he
thought that was a really smart move and
that would also you know get people
behind him so my read of that in
retrospect is it was a flex it was an
expression of confidence you know it was
like should be honest to show that you
think you can still get through it and
then in retrospect you're just like well
uh I guess it was Hubris then so what's
so interesting is during that blow up of
Terra Luna uh three arrows Capital uh
obviously came under immense stress and
you said I at the time three Euros
capitals fall looked like Samson
defeated but once FTX crumbled in
November 3ac looked like a different
metaphor the canary in the coal mine and
so it seems like now actually maybe that
one event is really what kicked off all
the contagion and yes uh some of the
things that happened later in 2022
obviously had an effect but really most
of the trouble that started for many of
these companies funds Etc was really
Terra Luna going down not the things
that happened later in the year those
were just kind of the final punch that
knocked out you know some of the firms
is that is that an accurate read
well I think that's an accurate read I
mean I also think another way to look at
all of it is
if you're in crypto for a minute you
should know that until this stuff
becomes mainstream
we're going to have a series of wild
rides up and you should probably get out
before the big rides up ends and then go
conservative and a bunch of people
didn't I mean you know Bitcoin I mean we
all know that Bitcoin is what marks the
height of this Market
um by the time Tara fell apart it had
been six months since Bitcoin bitcoin's
all-time high like you're insane to
still be playing hard six months in the
late after the bitcoin's all-time high
in a in a crypto Market you know so I
think yes I think Tara is a crucial part
of it but I think another crucial part
of it is just we know that this thing
has Cycles the cycle was clearly over
why are people still swinging for the
fences so that's interesting because uh
in another part of the book you talk
about uh Pierre Richard's tweet and uh
Pierre's been around for a long time in
the Bitcoin world and he tweeted out the
following he said easiest prediction
I'll ever make what a hot start to a
tweet easiest prediction I'll ever make
Fiat brained bozos try fractional
Reserve banking with Bitcoin and get
wrecked SBF fancies himself to be a
Savvy JP Morgan bails out the bozos he
puts in parentheses you are here then he
says which only encourages more bad
risk-taking SPF needs a bailout but you
can't print Bitcoin
in hindsight Pierre looks like
Nostradamus right yep yep were the
bitcoiners right was everything else
[__] and Sam Etc was just playing a
game that was unwinnable or was it a
case of bad risk taking and actually
there is uh you know some degree of
Truth to the things they were trying to
invest in or value created there uh and
it's more so bad risk-taking than it is
just like Bitcoin is the thing and
everything else is nonsense as if you
know what I think Pierre would argue
yeah I don't quite agree with Pierre on
that you know
um I think there's good things I mean it
might you know if you look at my
coverage I cover all kinds of things in
the crypto world I think a lot of is
interesting you know I mean on the flip
side one thing I'd point out is for
example
um a lot of crypto lenders blew up but
none of the defy lenders did you know
they all had some big liquidations but
it was all orderly you know there was
just like yep a bunch of money came out
you know nobody there was no defaults
you know went fine you know so I think I
think there's some plenty of good things
out there in the crypto World on the
ongoing slow build of this new industry
but we both know it's all prone to
irrational exuberance and people getting
too excited and even Bitcoin is prone to
that right I mean Bitcoin goes up above
where it should really be and it falls
back down you know kind of always each
time higher than the Pat the last level
of a rational exuber and so obviously
there's a real build of wealth happening
there
um a real build of value happening so I
think it's a mix of both but I'm still
very impressed by Pierre's call um you
know I missed that at the time I found I
found that in my research later but I
was just like this guy definitely
deserves credit for this oh this is
amazing you know it was absolutely
insane talk about what happened after
FTX blew up which kind of your read so
FTX uh freezes withdrawals and there's a
period of I think it was like nine ten
days
people on the internet are going wild
there are folks flying they're both
investors and FTX people who are not
happy with FTX
um there's all sorts of speculation and
debate there was a hack that happened
and some of the funds got drained like
talk a little bit as you did work in
terms of okay the blow up happens what
were those nine or ten days like
well the weirdest thing about a lot of
those days is something happened that
had never happened before
Sam went silence you know and that's one
of the things which uh Nathaniel
Whittemore really talks about on his on
his podcast uh afterwards once it's all
said and done and FDX is gone
um and FTX has gone into bankruptcy it's
just that like everybody was like what
the hell for the first time ever our our
CEO who won't shut up is not saying
anything and that was a a real source of
concern to lots of people and you know
I've got sources in there who are inside
the company and who are just like you
know look if Alameda goes under that's
no big deal they're just one market
maker you know in the company where we
are
um we're resilient against that we got
multiple market makers it should be no
problem and then more and more it
becomes clear that like no there is a
very big problem and then it looks like
there's a giant hole in the balance
sheet so
um yeah I mean I think almost
immediately it became clear that
something was wrong because Sam always
had something to say about everything
and all of a sudden he wasn't talking
and then eventually you know uh they
declared well they tried to sell the
binding chance which was out of control
and then uh and then when binance didn't
want to buy they declared bankruptcy
it's wild do you think CZ sleight of
hand it and knew he wasn't going to buy
it but kind of cut off all of their
options or do you think that that was
um you know kind of in the moment
everyone's trying to figure it out
um my colleague Dan Primark at axios uh
report did some reporting on this a
little bit at the time and you know who
knows it's all just impaired it's all
just um it's all just opinions and
things like that but his sources at the
time told him that what CeCe believed he
was doing was inflicting a little pain
on a rival who'd been kind of a jerk and
it turned out that there was way more
there than even he suspected so um I
think CZ was trying to slap Sam on the
wrist I don't really think he thought he
could sync the company with a tweet it
just turned out that there were much
bigger issues going on there than anyone
realized and that's what happened so um
I don't really I think I think CZ wanted
to hurt them he was just like if I sold
a bunch of ftt right now that would not
be good for them and I never do this so
everyone will notice it and then it just
turned out there was a much bigger
weakness there than anyone suspected so
you talk about towards the end of the
book uh sbf's uh maybe Public
Communication strategy and you say in
late November and early December SPF
would not leave the public eye he was in
magazines he was in the New York Times
he was doing interviews on YouTube he
was on Twitter spaces
and then you list a ton of people who
interviewed him you talk about the fact
that he goes to various conferences
including uh there's a recording of a
phone call with Tiffany Fong there's the
New York Times deal book Summit Good
Morning America New York Magazine the
scoop podcast uh axios interviews Etc
is that like a strategy is that just
like I'm gonna wing it what what's going
on there because I don't see very many
people when they're in this type of you
know hot water and scrutiny being like
let me jump on Twitter spaces and just
like anyone can ask me any questions let
me go on you know uh coffeezilla and let
him just ask me whatever he wants like
that's a very unique strategy
it is a unique strategy
um you know there are those out there
who think he had like Samurai level PR
people who were telling him to do this
to like you know flood the published
Consciousness and believe that there was
some chance that he was going to get
away with all he did because of that
I don't think that's true you know I
think that was Sam being Sam my least
charitable read of it is he believed he
was about to lose the public eye for
good and he was going to have his last
few tastes of Fame you know because he
enjoyed that attention my most
charitable read of it is he thought he
could you know kind of like do Quan
telling you this is how my this is how
my project falls apart he thought by
maximizing honesty he could convince the
world that uh he was innocent
um so but I really if you have if you
made me make a bet I would say it was
the former I think he was addicted to
the attention and couldn't get himself
to stop and didn't have people around he
knew how to tell him no yet and so he
just took all the attention he could get
because he thought he might never get it
again
so you also talk about some of the
investors you say FTX list of investors
spam powerful and well-known investment
firms I'm sorry this is New York Times
writing this ftx's list of investors
spans powerful and well-known investment
firms Nea ivp iconic third Point Tire
Global Ultima uh Lux Capital Mayfield
Insight Sequoia SoftBank Lightspeed
right I mean just go through the line
there's a ton a black rock uh uh
domestic Etc
what what do they all think now do you
have any sense in terms of you know is
this just a case of Fraud and fraud
happens in every market and uh if
somebody says they're doing one thing if
they're Auditors uh our tricked if
Regulators are tricked then you know we
shouldn't expect investors to be able to
uncover this or is there a little bit of
you know kind of egg on people's faces
and and uh maybe it's a different story
well I
uh Pop I gotta turn this question back
to you on some level um because you're
an actual investor and I'm I'm curious
about this my as someone who's not an
investor who's never been in any of the
rooms of any of these things I don't
really know my read is the way these
things work in a hot Market when
startups start to be in the driver's
seat they get to start sort of lowering
standards lowering standards and the
hotter a startup is the more demands
they can make of investors I mean is
that 100 I guess I mean do you know like
do you see your peers doing this are you
like how the hell did you sign this term
sheet like this point like does that
happen
I think that there is a laundry list of
situations that we saw over the last two
or three years that uh exact situation
played out I will say that sometimes
it's a negative right in terms of when
there's no board of directors there's no
diligence like those types of things
that's obviously not good this is a
example of what can happen in those
scenarios there's also a lot of
different examples where people took
money off the table or whatever and like
the businesses worked right and so like
in some weird way I think that investors
especially when they start out I was
like this uh early um in kind of my
investing career is like I want to
invest in companies and I want to be
really helpful right and it's like yeah
that's great okay cool that makes you
feel good because you're helpful and
maybe you're actually helping or maybe
you're not you learn right but what you
find over time is like the best
companies don't need your help right
maybe they need advice every once in a
while or they need a specific
introduction or whatever it's not like
they don't ever talk to the investors
but it's like when something's working
it's going to be very hard for outside
investors especially the smaller
investors in the rounds to have any
material impact on the business right
and so in some way it's like this like
uh self-selection thing where you want
to invest in the companies that don't
need your help and so naturally what
that means then is like you kind of are
asking them permission to invest in the
company and so a lot of these firms if
there's a bunch of competition to your
point then you can lower the standard
because there's so much demand I
actually don't know if it matters
whether you're an individual angel
investor or you're a very large firm
like in some way you may just come to
the conclusion like hey we don't want to
break any glass we're not going to get
invited to invest in the company right
and so you get this kind of kind of
weird thing what I also think though is
if somebody says send me your audited
financials and they're sent and for some
reason they end up not being true
it's kind of hard you know or is the
expectation that every single investor
is going to go and check the auditor's
work to make sure that the financials
that were audited and approved you know
are actually factual
um maybe right I don't want to say never
but I think that the point of having the
auditor is that the auditor is supposed
to be the one that is able to sign off
on it so if they get tricked it's kind
of hard for other people to do it and
you can extrapolate this from the
private markets of the public markets I
think that's the other thing right is
audited financials There are rules if
you submit financials that are
inaccurate right
but at the end of the day even public
hedge fund investors evaluating public
companies how many of them have the
ability let alone have the desire but
the ability to actually go and
underwrite some of this stuff outside of
what the auditor is saying or what a
regulator is saying and so you know it's
kind of like in a bad situation like oh
people should do more diligence 100
agree that that is definitely something
that has to play out in these bull
markets but you know somebody on Twitter
was yelling at me one time and they were
like uh how did you not know I was like
what questions you know would I ask
right and I wasn't an investor but but
um we had worked with their us-based
entity and he was like you should have
asked if they were taking all of the
crypto assets siphoning it into Alameda
and then making leverage risky Bets with
customer funds I said okay
if I had asked them that and they said
no then what right right and like in
some way that's kind of what people saw
in the terms of service and some of
these businesses some businesses say hey
we're doing x with the funds other
businesses say we're doing why with the
funds that's why it's written there
what's in what is unique or interesting
about this case is it appears at least
what's been reported that what the doc
said they were doing something different
and so again you know who uncovers that
in some way you know this is a case of
the free market uncovered it
right the market dynamics were able to
identify and expose this faster than any
of the kind of fail-safes or safety nets
that we put in place in terms of
Regulation auditing Etc and like whether
that's good or bad I'm not really sure
but like that just seems to be what
happened right yeah yeah
you know yeah I think I think that's
right and I don't I don't really know
what the clear solution is you know
people are doing this proof of reserves
thing right now obviously that is not
perfect you know
um but what else are you gonna do you
know there are to me there are other red
flags like I could get this wrong so you
know we can issue a correctional or
whatever my quote here is wrong but I do
think that this is this is what it said
in that crazy kind of um profile that
Sequoia put out about SPF right which I
mentioned a couple times in the story
and everyone talked about when it came
out it was just this remember that
glowing profile they put up on his site
they they hired this ex journalist you
know right of him there was a line in
that where I was just like
how can this possibly make sense it's in
the part of where he's doing the staff
meeting
and it might have been a smaller number
than this but I think what it was he
said he was he was like look guys we're
gonna have to reign in our spending a
little bit if there's expenditures over
100 I swear to God the number was 100
million dollars put it in there if it's
over 100 million dollars you're gonna
have to get pre-approval from some
managers otherwise you know good to go
and I was like
even if they raised four billion dollars
right which I think you know was the
amount they raised right
um 100 million dollars is still a
significant portion of four billion
dollars like how is how is that the
number that you have to have approvals
about and how did Sequoia print that
story and not go wait 100 million you
know like even if it was even if I'm
exaggerated by 10 even if it was 10
million I think it was 100 million you
know we could check but
um that still seemed like I mean I know
whatever the number was as I read it I
was like that's a crazy number how are
the investors not like more concerned
about that you know so
there were other red flags I feel like
but um yeah it also is um one of these
situations where it's so easy in
hindsight to put them all together right
but to your point like even the people
who are experts along the way
are okay maybe there's one thing that's
a little weird that's a little weird
whatever but like it's very hard to kind
of find this stuff and I've got a friend
who uh recently was having a lunch with
and I said to him you know what other
ones are hiding in plain sight
and we started talking about you know
what are the things that uh could
potentially be whether they're
fraudulent uh they're not what they say
they are uh maybe they're not going to
be as successful as people think they
are for whatever reason you know we're
going through kind of a bunch of
brainstorming of these things and he
said to me no actually I start my list
not with what are the riskiest things or
the things that people are are uh uh
suspecting I start my list with the
things that everyone thinks is the
safest I start my list with the thing of
that everyone trusts and I thought it
was just a really like like yes like
that is a great way to to kind of
compile a list right is actually like
what are the things that no one
questions that actually may have have an
issue if you kind of think about it and
so I I tend to think um you know when
when there's trust even if you have
decentralization even if you have kind
of all the the merits of uh what the
industry provides like there is still a
level of trust
right and I think that that is something
that doesn't get talked a lot about is
whether you trust a company whether you
trust a decentralized uh you know
platform whether you're literally just
trusting the fact that the information
you're looking at is accurate
right I always ask people you know hey
how many uh how many Bitcoin uh are in
circulation and they'll say a number and
I say okay cool did you read that on a
website or did you actually go run a
note and check
and a lot of people will just look at
the website even though they have the
ability to go check right and like guess
what like it takes a little bit longer
it requires you to do a little bit more
work like there's all these things as to
why people won't do it but even when you
can 100
000 check to make sure that the number
you're looking at is accurate
most people still just go look at the
website and so you there you introduce
trust and you know kind of this Reliance
on a third party
um which again Bitcoin promises not to
have to you know rely on but I think
people will still do it even if it's
available to go run the node and figure
it out for yourself
yeah well so I want to Circle back to
this how you could know in advance but
on that on that score
um you know one of the things I always
feel like a bit of a jerk about every
time there's a big blow up in crypto and
I do think this is does make me kind of
a jerk but also I do think it's sort of
right is like you'll see a lot of these
mainstream media stories that they'll
talk about people who lost everything
you know when and the blow up happens
and they'll be these cases of people
like I had my entire life savings in
like whatever coin or whatever thing and
it like lost all this and I've lost all
of it and that really sucks and I feel
bad for that person but I'm also just
like
if you were in this space at all and you
were listening to any of the responsible
long-term people in here I guarantee you
they were all saying don't go all in on
anything you know like they all say that
again and again and again like you I'm
sure you know I know you're the biggest
Bitcoin pain on the planet you wouldn't
tell anybody to put a hundred percent of
their of their Capital into Bitcoin I
don't think I'll take it even a step
further when a lot of this stuff blew up
there were people who were yelling and
screaming at me on the internet they
were so mad right
um uh the us-based FTX thing uh blockfi
Etc and I was sitting there and I was
like
through 2017 2018 I was one of the
biggest anti-ico people in the whole
world I literally was just saying like I
think this is all [__] I think that
the SEC is going to step in whatever
took a while but like here they are
right uh the second thing is uh I was
the person who uh popularized the idea
of get off zero like literally go from
zero to like a dollar go from a zero to
you know hundred dollars whatever and
then the third thing was people used to
get mad at me in the bull market when I
would say on National Television or
anything you know I don't know maybe
most people are putting one to five
percent of their portfolio into this and
people be like how could you not tell
them to put more like you know the
Dollar's going to zero whatever
the bear Market it's like it's your
fault everyone lost savings and I just
sit there and just be like the the two
things can't be true right like they
can't both be true and and I think I
share your sentiment of like I feel bad
for anyone who is harmed in any Market
when things go down I mean we now are
seeing obviously you know people who
took out adjustable rate mortgages and
the FED Heights interest rates and now
all of a sudden their mortgage payment
triples
but again at some point we have to have
this idea of like self-reliance and
self-responsibility as well right and so
it doesn't uh completely excuse
everyone's Behavior right because
obviously people have a responsibility
when they have a platform all this type
of stuff but I do think there's this
very weird uh Dynamic where uh because
of the way that attention works the most
egregious extreme stories are the ones
that get pushed the hardest and so to
your point the like person who took a
hundred thousand dollars that they had
to their name and put it all into an
obscure crypto coin there's a lot to
unpack there and it's not just like hey
the coin went down and so the people who
made the coin are bad right right right
so I want to Circle back to this idea of
could we have foreseen it you know for
folks I you know hopefully your
listeners pick up the book and have a
look one of the things about how the
book works is it goes all the way to the
back to the beginning of Sam in crypto
up to when you know uh the end of last
year and one of the things I do think as
I Revisited that story and again I
wasn't smart enough to see this in the
time at the time but there is a way and
and you know you know as having read the
book one of the themes of the book kind
of is just sort of I have a sort of like
spiritual language like you read one of
the things in there about the Greek
tragedies and things and I sort of I
sort of come back to like you know the
gods don't like it when you do this like
that kind of thing a variety of times
and part of the reason why I do that I
like that kind of language but I also
did it because when you look back over
the year there's some other ways in
which it was almost like the universe
was making warnings so two examples that
I have in the book in there are cream
finance and mango and mango markets both
of which were instances where
um where well cream Finance was a case
where the community pushed back against
Sam making gigantic bets against ftt
using the platform they were just like
we're going to put some breaks on this
you know that was a community realizing
that you shouldn't go all in an [__] so
on some level I I saw that as kind of a
warning to the world about about uh the
story and then mango markets was like
almost exactly the same thing as what
happened a month and a half later with
FTX you know mango markets was this
decentralized exchange on um on Solana
that allowed people to make bets against
its native currency which was Manga
which was obviously a tiny tiny currency
that was thinly traded and you know this
guy of uh Abraham Eisenberg you know
pulled this uh hustle where he made the
price of mango go up really high
borrowed all of the capital that was on
their uh credit thing and just walked
away from it let us let his loan go bad
and it was just like
and and of course Sam went on to Twitter
afterwards and talked about how like
they had poor safety measures on Mango
and FTX had much better safety measures
but I'm looking at that story and I'm
just like wow this is the story about an
exchange that let you take out excess
collateral against its native token you
know can we think of another exchange
that did the same thing oh right the FTX
did you know so it's like the universe
does on some level provide warnings of
these things you've just got to be you
just got to be paying attention to when
it gives the warnings and and so those
stories are in the book and that's why
they're in there I think that that makes
uh makes a ton of sense the book is
called SBF how the FTX bankruptcy
Unwound crypto's very bad good guy which
is a [__] amazing title uh where can
we send people to find the book
uh well definitely go to your local
Bookshop and ask them to order it tell
them you'd be excited for them to have
lots of copies there obviously it's up
on Amazon already you can order it from
there also bookshop.org if you want to
order it from uh you know a local
Bookshop that way but yeah I mean the
best thing folks could do is go to their
local Bookshop and be like hey I can't
wait for this book to come in you should
have tons and tons of copies um that
would be fantastic I think that is a a
great thing I've had a lot of authors
come on here no one has ever said that
so you know what you're doing which I
appreciate uh pretty where can we send
people to find you on Twitter and if
they want to follow up after this ask
questions whatever where uh where should
they do that
yeah I'm at Brady Dale on Twitter also
would love for folks to search axios
cryptocurrency And subscribe to our
newsletter we put a newsletter out every
single day uh me and my colleague
Crystal Kim I think it's pretty good
um I think folks will like that so yeah
the the Twitter and uh and my answer us
newsletter would both be great amazing
Brady I always enjoyed talking to you
the book was fantastic uh I don't think
that I've ever read a book about
something that I like lived through and
was like oh yeah there's a bunch in here
that I didn't know even as it was going
on so I appreciate all the hard work it
goes into writing this and I hope that
people go pick it up SPF how the FTX
bankruptcy Unwound crypto's very bad
good guy for those that are watching on
YouTube yes I have the spiral bound uh
version uh which just means that uh I
got to look at it before you but you
should go buy it because that's awesome
uh Brady thank you so much we will uh
we'll definitely do this again in the
future
thanks Mom